PROFESSOR: I love ice cream.
It's one of life's simple pleasures, but
the science that's much more complex.
At its core, ice cream is a
product of phase transition,
in this case, water freezing into ice.
Two things that greatly impact
the texture of ice cream
are the amount of the water and
ice cream base that freezes,
and how quickly that
transition takes place.
So one of the biggest
challenges for the home cook
is making ice cream that is dense,
smooth, and free of noticeable iciness.
What's interesting is that
all things being equal,
ice cream that we perceive as
icy, doesn't actually contain
more ice crystals, just bigger ones.
The crystals in smooth ice cream are
so small that our tongues can't even
detect them.
So there are two basic ways to prevent
ice cream from having an icy texture.
The first is to control
the water in the base.
Now this could mean reducing
the overall water content.
It could also mean keeping more
of the water in liquid form
by adjusting sweeteners.
Sweeteners lower the freezing
point of the water in the mixture,
preventing some of it
from turning to ice.
Or you can use ingredients like
starches and gums, which trap free water
and prevent it from
forming large ice crystals.
The second way to
prevent an icy texture is
to make sure that the ice crystals
that do form are as small as possible.
Here, we're talking
about rate of freezing.
The faster you freeze ice cream, the
smaller the ice crystals will be.
Now commercial ice
cream manufacturers have
a lot of advantages over the home cook,
when it comes to making ice cream.
They have powerful stabilizers
and professional freezers
and blast chillers that can turn a
liquid custard into a semi-solid ice
cream in a matter of seconds.
It's not something you could
do at home, and believe me,
in America's Test Kitchen, we tried to.
So here are the ingredients
for our vanilla ice cream.
I'm using a combination
of heavy cream and milk
for the right level of richness.
Now fat also helps reduce the
perception of ice crystals
by lubricating your tongue.
Now I'm using fresh vanilla
bean for its complex flavor,
and I'm going to add it early in the
process the maximum flavor out of it.
So next up, we have the sweeteners,
which have a huge impact on texture.
I'll come back to that
point in just a minute.
Here, I'm using granulated
sugar, which is pretty common,
and corn syrup, which is not.
Corn syrup is a combination of sweet
glucose molecules, which make it sweet,
and chains of broken cornstarch.
So it's these chains
of tangled cornstarch
which give corn syrup it's viscosity.
Now, in our ice cream, they
prevent water molecules
from grouping and freezing
into big crystals.
PROFESSOR: So since we're thinking
about ice cream, at the moment,
let's imagine freezing it.
If we cool it, then we know
that without the sugar or salt,
the temperature at which
the water becomes a solid
is zero degrees Celsius.
And that's because the entropy of
the water molecules moving around
becomes balanced by the sticking energy
of that water molecules to each other
to make the crystal.
If there's salt or sugar in
the water, that salt and sugar
has an additional entropy that is
besides the entropy of the water
molecules.
There's also an entropy
of the salt molecule.
So you can imagine these little
molecules jiggling around.
And when you freeze
the mixture, you have
to also stop the motion of the solute
molecules of the sugar or salt.
And that requires a little
extra energy than you
would have had to give it otherwise.
So this extra energy
leads to the phenomenon
that people call freezing
point depression.
This is the notion that
if you actually try
to freeze a mixture of
salt water or sugar water,
you have to actually go
to a lower temperature
to freeze it than you would if
there were no salt and sugar.
That lower temperature
is to actually get rid
of the extra energy that's needed to
actually stop the solute from moving.
Freezing point depression essentially
depends on the entropy of the solute.
And as such, the amount that you have
to actually depress the freezing point
really depends on the number of
solute molecules per unit volume
that you've managed to put in.
The more you put in, the more
the freezing point is depressed.
If we think about this when making ice
cream, it raises a bit of a conundrum.
So if you make ice
cream, you all recall,
or you will know soon
enough, when you do the lab,
that the recipe for
ice cream, essentially,
involves taking milk, which of
course has little fat globules
and other things in it.
It's basically water with fat
globules and other molecules.
And you then poor sugar in the milk,
because you'd like it to be sweet.
And then you need to
freeze the sweet milk.
Now, if you freeze the sweet milk by
surrounding it by just normal ice, just
normal frozen water, it won't freeze.
And the reason is is because a
freezing point depression the mixture
has a lower freezing
point than the water.
So somehow, you have to get the material
that's around the milk with sugar in it
to have a lower freezing
point than that of the milk,
and a way to do that is to
add salt. So if you add salt,
you will, of course, depress the
freezing point of the salt water.
If you then freeze that, it
will have a lower temperature
than the freezing point
of the milk-sugar mixture,
and that will allow you to
freeze it and make ice cream.
PROFESSOR: So let's scoop some
and see what it looks like.
So as you can see, it's
nice and thick and dense.
And I'll take a little
try, just to make sure it's
good and doesn't have any ice.
That's good.
It's really nice and dense, very smooth,
and there's really no noticeable ice
crystals, because we
made them nice and small.
So by understanding and controlling
the phase transition of water to ice,
we get ice cream that's
scoopable right from the freezer.
It's dense, it's creamy, and most
importantly, perfectly smooth.